whether it's struggling as parents going
into space or creating their own theme
park there's a lot to YouTube Sensations
dude perfect that you might not know
well Sports and trick shots might be
what the group is best known for the
individual members of Dude Perfect all
have separate interests for Tyler Tony
it's a love of hunting and fishing Tony
told modern Huntsman being in the
outdoors has always been synonymous with
time spent around my grandfathers and my
dad I can remember being five years old
and taking my BB gun and just following
my dad around our deer lease this
childhood love can still be seen on
Tony's Instagram feed where he poses
with his catches which includes a 350
pound blue marlin Tony has claimed that
he wants to use Dude Perfect in order to
change the reputation of hunting saying
to Modern Huntsman I would hope that
kids and adults alike would look at that
and say hey you know what I eat meat why
wouldn't I give this a shot and see what
this whole hunting and conservation
thing is like well Tony is a huge part
of both dude perfect and the growing
social hunting scene and he is seen
first and foremost as a family man
marrying his wife Bethany in 2011 the
pair has gone on to have three children
however the journey to Parenthood wasn't
smooth sailing for them with Tyler and
Bethany openly discussing their
struggles on the YouTube series I am
second Bethany revealed that Tony left
for the first Dude Perfect Tour only a
week after the middle son was brought
home from the hospital I was at home
building up all of this resentment and
bitterness in these walls the pair
explained that their family reached the
breaking point when Bethany found out
she was pregnant with their youngest son
while Bethany struggled with being a
mother of three largely on her own Tyler
reportedly rebuilt his relationship with
his faith to help repair his marriage
admitting when you have a community of
people around you who are able to reveal
some of those things to you your
perspective can change in those
situations one of the most frequently
asked questions for the Dude Perfect
boys is the story of how they all met in
their YouTube documentary Dude Perfect
backstage pass the guys go into their
friendship in Greater detail back in
2007 the five met at Texas A M
University in College Station though
it's known for its academic success its
sporting Legacy isn't far behind Tyler
finally remembered meeting the cotton
twins claiming I showed up at their
house and they're learning the Soulja
Boy dance on their projector I was like
okay I guess I can get on board with
that Kobe cotton explained that he ended
up living in a house with his twin
brother Corey and with Tony between
their Mutual disdain for their classes
and instant love of spending time in
nature and evolving Sports it wasn't
long before the friends began filming
themselves trying to land stunts one
basketball trick video was posted to
YouTube and the rest was history with
front row tickets for Dude Perfect going
for as much as 350 dollars per person
it's safe to say that the excitement
about seeing live trick shots hasn't
weighed since a group's formation in
2009 years of touring have also provided
the boys with the knowledge to continue
their ongoing success for them
incorporating music game show elements
and audience participation into a
whirlwind experience of sports and point
scoring though incredible trick shots
still make up a huge part of what they
do the group site segments like their
comedic sketches as some of the most
popular videos they have created in Dude
Perfect backstage pass there group
explained that it was important to adapt
their rage monster content for their
live shows due to its overwhelming
popularity
but we knew that we had to figure out a
way to put the rage monster in the live
tour just because it's everybody's
favorite but it's also one of the most
fun things to do for me Tony and Garrett
Hilbert explained to Modern Huntsman
that after dude Perfect's first
basketball trick shot video gained
traction on YouTube gaining the
attention of the national press they had
no idea what they were doing or where
they were going Tony explained her first
brand deal was nine years ago and we had
no idea what we were getting into we
sent it to my dad who ran that first
brand deal for us and went on to become
our business manager when things started
picking up for the group all five
members of Dude Perfect still had
full-time jobs according to their
documentary it was a collective decision
to quit their jobs and take the plunge
that made the platform successful
instead of working nine to five and
making all of their content on the
weekend Gilbert told modern Huntsman at
one point we were all in job Transitions
and thought we might as well give this
dude perfect thing a go full time since
we decided to do that it just exploded
though the decision to focus full time
on the Dude Perfect platform was the one
that ultimately made the group a success
it was also the thing that almost drove
the group apart in Dude Perfect
backstage as Kobe cotton explained we
were all living in different cities a
couple of guys got married
we all started new jobs they agreed that
making money let alone a career off
videos posted to YouTube was almost
unheard of at the time while Dude
Perfect was trying to juggle their jobs
with filming content on the Goodyear
blimp in 2012. Tony received a call from
his boss berating him for missing too
much work while it initially felt as
though he would be the first to leave
they all decided to Double Down Cody
Jones explained there were all these
opportunities on her doorstep and we
took advantage of it after Dude Perfect
became a legitimate job for the famous
five the platform became a brand name
while the boys could have kept it just
shooting basketballs through hoops from
crazy Heights diversifying different
segments of their branding was much
easier than it seems in his interview
with free the pen Prairie cotton
explained that turning their story into
a book felt like a true calling arrested
in the fact that at the end of the day I
obeyed Jesus with a call to write a book
about all that he's allowed us to do
over the past two years the Dude Perfect
documentary delves deeper Behind these
projects with a group acknowledging that
Cotton's book a merchandise line a
series of games and a TV show all came
along in relatively quick fashion their
sudden expansion of the brand was also
the reason that the group decided they
needed a permanent base setting up their
first headquarters in Frisco Texas in
August 2022 thanks to a partnership
between dude perfect and the crypto
company Moon Deo Kobe cotton was
involved in the 29th launch of blue
origins new Shepard rocket technically
making him an astronaut though the
flight itself only lasted 10 minutes
cotton actually beat out his fellow Dude
Perfect members through a model rocket
competition in order to be one of the
six crew members on new Shepherds made
in Voyage oh Cody's supposed to joke and
a half Ty sorry about you but I'm going
to take this from from your hands in the
last second I'm going to space Corey and
Kobe Cotton's first names might trip
some fans tongues confusing them more
than necessary however according to
multiple fans and celebrity Outlets
these aren't their actual given names
Corey's birth name is William and Kobe's
name is John from a branding and content
perspective Kobe and Corey aren't just
catchy monikers for the twins but they
also tie in phonetically with fellow
Dude Perfect member Cody Jones but the
individual names of the Dude Perfect
Squad isn't the only weird coincidence
between them all members except for
Tyler Tony were born in 1987. Garrett
Hilbert's is the oldest but the cotton
twins being two months after him and
Cody Jones three months after that Tyler
Tony was born two years later in 1989
making him the youngest of the bunch
though it's all fun and games in front
of the camera there has been plenty of
work that has gone on behind the scenes
to get the guys to where they are a lot
of this responsibility fell into the lap
of Corey cotton who fronted the original
editing team however his dedication to
editing had a nasty side effect in Dude
Perfect backstage pass cotton explained
that he struggled with Bell's Palsy as a
results of spending too much time
editing videos
I move my mouth and I realized like one
side of my face was totally paralyzed
this dude perfect has continued to grow
cotton is no longer actively involved in
the editing the fact that the dude
perfect team is fully invested in their
Christian faith will come as no surprise
to hardcore fans a 2020 video segment
for CBN News showed the group praying
while on a charity visit for the
Make-A-Wish Foundation the sense of
worship went one step further for Cody
Jones whose Devotion to Christianity
turned a corner while at University
Jones became a Grace Bible youth leader
while at Texas A M around the same time
he made friends with the dude perfect
gang the Grace Bible youth group's
reported aim is to transform the lives
of young students to Christianity though
details of Cody's exact involvement in
the group are unknown though it's well
known that he's not the only one who has
leaned into his fate in line with their
values Dude Perfect announced in late
2022 that they would be opening a
Christian family-friendly entertainment
center when Dude Perfect first slept
onto YouTube's homepage their impressive
talents were almost universally
acclaimed however as more time has
passed some people become wary of their
seemingly effortless trick shots
commenters on YouTube and in online
forums have put forward faking theories
ranging from clever editing transitions
to full-body green morph suits some
Reddit users are supposedly convinced
that dude perfect uses undisclosed CGI
in their content word on the street is
our trick shots are fake how we even do
that
in response the Dude Perfect boys have
displayed a pretty good sense of humor
about it all uploading multiple videos
poking fun at the idea that the team
uses extra effects to get results the
more the fans have discussed the issue
over time the more they've agreed that
it's much more likely that the team just
tries to trick repeatedly until they
eventually get it right in 2019 Dude
Perfect took their work to a new level
by taking the best of their trick shots
and putting them on the big screen in
dude perfect trick shots not only were
fans given exclusive commentary for the
most well-known pranks and challenges in
the Channel's history but the boys also
provided hidden secrets and never before
seen tricks that were exclusive to the
film The boys threw basketballs out of
planes kayak down escalators and used a
tree as a giant slingshot across a
football field all in a day's work
really the 90 minutes of untold stories
wasn't only a hit with younger viewers
but parents have also commented that
dude perfect trick shots shows young
audiences a good-natured rivalry between
positive role models with fans still
trying to replicate their trick shots to
this day the media impact of Dude
Perfect goes beyond their videos and
movie as time has marched on and fans
have become more familiar with dude
Perfect's formats it could be said that
the boys may have finally run out of
surprises some Reddit users have
commented on the pace of the platform
within the last year picking up on
changes in their personal interactions
and more heavily critiquing the quality
of their content however since Dude
Perfect was involved with the 2023 NFL
draft and with the boy's Twitter account
teasing something even bigger and better
to come the group might be about to take
its Audience by surprise while the
eventual announcement could take the
shape of something we've seen before
Dude Perfect could be easily launching
itself into entirely new territory a
recent report from The Wall Street
Journal suggests that the boys could be
looking to grow their brand
internationally
thank you
[Music]